I always expected this election to be
exceptionally difficult for the Liberal
Democrats given the heavy
responsibilities we've had to bear in
government in the most challenging of
circumstances but clearly the results
have been immeasurably more crushing and
unkind than I could ever have feared for
that of course I must take
responsibility and therefore I announce
that I will be resigning as leader of
the Liberal Democrats a leadership
election will now take place according
to the party's rules for the last seven
years it's been a privilege huge
privilege unlimited honor to lead a
party of the most resilient courageous
and remarkable people the Liberal
Democrats are a family and I will always
be extremely proud of the warmth good
grace and good humor which our political
family has shown through the ups and
downs of recent years so I want to thank
every member every campaigner every
councillor and every parliamentarian for
the commitment you have shown to our
country and to our party it is simply
heartbreaking to see so many friends and
colleagues who have served their
constituents so diligently over so many
years abruptly lose their seats because
of forces entirely beyond their control